[Música]
voy a compartir con ustedes por primera
vez la imagen de quién fue por muchos
años mi peor en advierto es una imagen
perturbador
al menos más
lo conocen se les hace de su cara
familiar bueno si es así es porque lo
tienen aquí enfrente ese es héctor citó
en sus primeros años de vida
pero no sé por qué y cómo llegué a odiar
a ese niño simple y sencillamente yo no
quería hacerlo tal vez el hecho de que
mi padre murió cuando yo tenía un año y
mi madre pues se tuvo que ir a trabajar
y dejarnos a mis hermanas ya mí solos al
cuidado de otras personas lo que influyó
pero yo realmente me la estaba pasando
muy mal
recuerdo que me sentía solo y cómodo
inadaptado
y si hoy soy actor y conductor de
televisión pero aunque no lo crean
cuando era niño era extremadamente
tímido y no sobresalía en nada mal
estudiante cero deportista no era
especialmente bonito y además eran muy
malos para relacionarme con los demás en
una ocasión mi hermana me compartió una
foto hace un par de años donde estamos
los primos en casa de los abuelos
obviamente hago lo que todo el mundo
hace no le empiezo a hacer zoom para
ubicarme y ver qué tan guapo salí
o decepción no soy el más guapo de la
foto de hecho soy el niño que está a la
derecha con su mamá tratando de meterlo
en la foto llorando
vean eso tremendo berrinche el que estoy
haciendo
hasta el pañal en esta calle
[Música]
el tema es que cuando yo vi esa foto
realmente me impactó porque yo me
recordé que yo así era que yo así me
sentía siempre sencillamente yo no
quería estar en nada no quería
participar en nada y aclaro algo a pesar
de que mi papá no estuvo y que vivíamos
en una situación económica bastante
apretada en mi casa nunca faltó lo más
importante era amor mi madre se gastó su
vida y su salud tratando de que
tuviéramos lo necesario y un poquito más
y siempre en un hogar lleno de amor de
paz de comunicación sin embargo yo no me
la estaba pasando bien
y si así fue mi infancia imagínense mi
adolescencia cuando yo estaba en un
lugar y se acercaba la chica que me
gustaba yo empezaba a tratar de mediar y
disfrutar como lo estoy haciendo ahorita
y cuando por fin se me ocurría decir
algo decía la peor estupidez que se me
podía ocurrir y la pobre muchacha salía
huyendo por esa razón mi primera novia
la tuve después de los 20 años pero
bueno esta fiesta historia tuvo un punto
de quiebre una ocasión llamaron a mi
madre a la dirección del colegio donde
yo estudiaba para decirle que por mi mal
desempeño escolar y educativo éste iban
a quitarme la beca que me permitía
estudiar en un colegio privado y que
posiblemente me tenían que expulsar esa
fue la primera vez que yo vi a mi madre
llorar por mi culpa rogándole al
director que por favor me diera una
segunda oportunidad y esa imagen
[Música]
ese día yo me di cuenta que tenía que
hacer algo para terminar con mi
sufrimiento y el sufrimiento de esa
mujer
y entonces me di cuenta que tenía dos
opciones terminar con mi historia o
empezar una nueva afortunadamente nunca
pensé realmente en atentar contra mi
vida así que tomé el plan p
y a partir de ese momento comenzó
el yo considero el viaje más excitante
emocionante y gratificante que he tenido
en mi vida el viaje hacia mi propia
transformación y evolución mi historia
personal de cambio y yo les quiero
compartir tres puntos tres pasos que me
ayudaron a mí a cambiar del primero
yo decidió cambiar una vez leí qué
los seres humanos cambiamos por dos
razones por inspiración o por
desesperación por inspiración no hace
falta que te pase algo malo simple y
sencillamente pues te motiva si cambias
ojalá siempre fuera así el problema es
que la mayoría de los seres humanos
-este necesitamos sentirnos incómodos
para hacer algo al respecto y luego
cambiar y bueno
eso es lo que me pasó a mí en este
asunto de cambiar por desesperación soy
experto
hace poco vi un vídeo de un rabino
llamado abraham tú eres y él hace una
comparación de todo esto con lo que le
pasa a una langosta la langosta es un
animal con un cuerpo suave pero tiene un
caparazón duro y rígido y cuando el
animal de langosta desea crecer entonces
baja a aguas profundas y seguras para
cambiar de caparazón una y otra vez
obviamente lo que hace que la langosta
baje es porque se siente incómoda y si
nos interesa en comodidad
entonces seguiría creciendo y morir y
aplastar en su propio caparazón esto
quiere decir que el estímulo que le
permite a la langosta crecer es sentirse
incómoda y en ese sentido yo soy
totalmente como una langosta y se los
digo por experiencia todos los cambios
positivos que han habido en mi vida han
sido precedidos por una profunda
sensación de insatisfacción e
inconformidad
incomodidad
siguiente punto
imagínate distinto cuando yo decidí que
quería cambiar me di cuenta que no tenía
ni los recursos ni el dinero ni conocía
a las personas adecuadas que me ayudaran
a cambiar pero si tenía algo que era
completamente mío y que podía utilizar
perfectamente cuando yo quisiera mi
mente
no me representaba ningún esfuerzo
pensar
ningún gasto soñar es gratis y también
aprendí que la única persona que piensa
en mi cabeza soy yo y que yo decido qué
pensamientos quiero pensar así que a
partir de ese momento yo active un
mecanismo de imaginarme totalmente
distinto y no solamente distinto
imaginarme mejor imaginarme más guapo
más exitoso más extrovertido de
imaginarme feliz cuando yo era niño y
veía un espectáculo en la televisión o
en el teatro como hace 1 punto que aquí
estaba este grupo folclórico veracruzano
yo los veía y me empezaba a entrar una
ansiedad porque yo no quería estar
sentado en la butaca yo quería estar
aquí bailando no es este el zapateado
jarocho entonces cuando yo me iba a mi
casa me encerraba en mi cuarto le ponía
frente al espejo y empezaba a bailar ya
cantar y hacer huecas y caras ahí
aprendí la cara del míster min
y un día dije quiero cantar y empecé a
cantar y no sé si lo hacía bien o mal
pero a mí me gustaba hacerlo y empecé a
cantar en todos lados cantaba en la casa
en el jardín del vecino por una manguera
en vez de micrófono y signada de
audiencia y público que me habló que
innovación hará pero yo era
extremadamente feliz y luego empecé a
cantar en la regadera y en la iglesia y
en el transporte público y eventualmente
pues terminé cantando en un escenario si
el escenario de el gimnasio de mi
colegio pero un escenario al fin ya mí
me pasaba algo realmente extraordinario
cuando héctor citó el niño tímido se
paraba en el escenario
hagan de cuenta era poseído por el
espíritu de frank sinatra y sentía una
seguridad
y un aplomo hasta seductor me diría mi
familia y mis amigos decían que por qué
te pasa en el escenario es una persona
completamente distinta a si todo lo que
leer en la vida real lo era en el
escenario y yo no sabía que me pasaba
pero me pasaba y era extremadamente
feliz y yo solamente fluía en una
ocasión platicando con el conductor de
televisión chileno don francisco él me
decía que él se enamoró del escenario
cuando escuchó su primer aplauso y yo
pensé no
a mí me pasó distinto yo me enamoré del
escenario cuando escuché el primer
silencio
cientos de personas viendo y escuchando
me solamente a mí
así como los tengo ahora
y se me hizo extremadamente fascinante y
extremadamente adictivo entonces qué
sucedió
me volví adicto a visualizar ya soñar
entonces agarraba la idea de como yo
quería hacer y la clavaba en mi mente
una y otra vez y obsesivamente la
pensaba una y otra vez y entonces algo
empezaba a suceder en mi entorno y de
repente mi madre mía que aparecía la
persona correcta en el momento indicado
para ayudarme a realizar el sueño y me
llegaban oportunidades que yo no había
buscado y se me abrían puertas que nunca
había imaginado cruzar y yo empecé a
cambiar cambió mi energía cambió mi
personalidad hasta físicamente cambie ya
no estaba tan venido como antes
me di cuenta que cuando yo pensaba en lo
que quería y me aferraba ese pensamiento
hagan de caso que el universo se
convertían como en el genio de la
lámpara que me decía pide un deseo
y un día pensé
quiero grabar un mismo
y que creen que pasó
llegó el disco
si no verde de magia eso pasó después de
un año y medio de mucho esfuerzo de
tocar puertas de conseguir dinero de
buscar conexiones y contactos que me
ayudaron y llegó el disco recuerdo que
cuando me lo entregaron era así porque
era un disco grande un lp de vinilo me
acuerdo que lo vi y no expresé nada y me
dice el de la compañía disquera no te
gusto no te veo emocionado no sé si está
está perfecto lo que pasa es que durante
un año y medio tuve este disco en mi
cabeza que hoy que lo tengo en mis manos
mi mente no percibe la diferencia entre
el sueño y la realidad
otro día dije me gustaría viajar a
méxico y trabajar en la televisión
mexicana
y que creen que pasó
también sucedió
también les digo no fue fácil porque
algo que también aprendí es que soñar se
solamente soñar o imaginarlo no es
suficiente los sueños mezclados con
preparación trabajo duro fe constancia
disciplina inevitablemente se convierten
en realidad
soñar es una capacidad que todos los
seres humanos desarrollamos cuando somos
niños pero que desafortunadamente se nos
olvida cuando crecemos así que por favor
no dejes de soñar siguiente
créetelo eso es muy importante por lo
menos se lo creyeran estarían del otro
lado a qué me refiero sí que decidiste
que quieres cambiar sí que hiciste de la
visualización un ejercicio diario lo que
sigue es creer que ese que quiere ser ya
lo eres y actuar en función de eso a qué
me refiero es echar a andar todos tus
pensamientos para poder hablar pensar
actuar vestir no en función de lo que
eres ahora sino en función de lo que
quiere ser esta es una verdad universal
y extremadamente antigua bueno hasta en
la biblia lo dice dice en la biblia que
dios usa palabras para llamar las cosas
que no son como si ya fueran y ahí les
da un ejemplo yo tenía un amigo llamado
a fernando en la escuela de actuación de
televisa me acuerdo que cuando nos
graduamos luego me lo encontraba era en
los pasillos de televisa pues buscando
trabajo como yo haciendo castings
audiciones y en una ocasión me di cuenta
de que fernando y yo íbamos de manera
totalmente
distinta yo iba pues como estoy vestido
ahorita igual con una camisa de vestir
nada más
fernando iba a pegarle un traje miembro
ancha dow por bata perfumado bien
peinado el zapato brillante pero deja en
la ropa la actitud no no no no
fernando caminado en la empresa así con
una seguridad y una elegancia como si
fuera el dueño de televisa y saludaba
no no no si esto le pasa
es más un día estábamos platicando él y
yo adentro de televisa y de repente
pronto desaparece y se va a saludar un
alto ejecutivo de la compañía y me deja
hablando solo y este que le pasa
animal
el avispón me deja que hablando solo
nombre ya se le subió y se lo conoce
bueno pasaron algunos años y yo un día
me encontré a mí mismo en mi casa en mi
cuarto solo desempleado sin hacer nada a
las cinco de la tarde viendo la
televisión y de repente veo
amigo fernando anunciando su primer
protagónico en una telenovela
entenderá lección alimentario el 20 y me
di cuenta de que fernando había hecho lo
correcto él siempre se la creyó él
siempre se movió desde que estaba en la
escuela y después ver a un actor
desempleado como yo siempre se movió se
vistió y actuó en función no de lo que
era en función de la gran estrella que
sabía que algún día se iba a convertir y
que hoy es tal vez lo conocen se llama
fernando columna y colunga
hoy puede seguir presumiendo de ser uno
de los actores mejor pagados en la
industria de la televisión de américa
latina'
fernando simple y sencillamente se les
creyó
para terminar quisiera
y decirles que para mí el haber cambiado
no solamente me salvó la vida me
permitió cumplir mis sueños el haber
cambiado me permitió dedicarme hoy a lo
que más me gusta para no tener que
trabajar me permitió tener la familia
que siempre soñé pero sobre todo cambiar
le permitió reconciliarme con mi peor en
él
hoy puedo ver este niño
y decirle que lo amo
decirle que lo necesito que por favor no
deje de ser niño qué
que no deje de jugar pero deje de
divertirse que no deje de equivocarse
que no dejen de soñar
abrazarlo y decirle que lo amo y que no
se preocupe por nada porque todo vais
para resumir número uno decide cambiar
aunque sea por desesperación y ahí les
va algo si ustedes se sienten
insatisfechos con su vida con su trabajo
con su relación con su físico
felicidades porque están en la antesala
de su propia evolución y transformación
y eso solamente puede traer cosas buenas
número 2 hagan de visualizar un
ejercicio diario y constante número 3
crean celo ya levántense todas las
mañanas dando gracias por estar vivos
disfruten su vida pongan en su cara una
hermosa sonrisa pongan su mejor ropa y
salgan de su casa caminando como colunga
a comerse el mundo porque esta vida no
tolera a los perdedores y tú eres un
ganador soy héctor sandarti y fue un
placer estar con ustedes gracias
[Aplausos]